so I had the chickenpox and I was
obsessed with Rob he as everybody on the
planet was I was in a long line of
people who just loved you so much and
somehow you heard I got the chickenpox
and you called me
not for sure that my mom was playing a
trick on me in a really sweet way and
I'll never forget like the house we
lived in the phone I was on where I was
in the room I can picture the room where
it happened and we talked and and then
you invited me to your birthday party
that's right and I came and it was the
best night of my life you you you were
so great on the Dance Floor cutting it
up you were like like a little mini
Madonna
which is exactly what I was going yes
[Applause]
it was